foreign
with a pretty face what's up Chantel
Hi how are you partying what are you up
to
um not partying I just lied to you I
just straight lied to you on my show
sorry I'm not I'm just at work let's
let's figure it out dude what's up
um so four years ago I was a cyclist hit
by a truck
to heal both uh legal and medically are
still ongoing so for very long years
um the length of time passing is just
like picking an old wound over and over
and over again when I just want to heal
and get past it how can I rebuild my
resilience when time and obligations
keep beating me down
oh how honest can I be with you
Barry you're not gonna like it Chantelle
can we still be friends I'm used to
tough realities do what
I'm very used to tough realities
okay
the moment you decide I'm gonna stop
trying to get past all of this
and instead shift your body energy and
your focus to I'm going to metabolize
this as this is my life this is a part
of my one tiny little precious life
then resilience can begin to do its work
and grow roots in you
right now you have a electric leaf
blower and you keep blowing the soil off
and The Roots can't take hold because
you're waiting for this thing to be over
you keep cleaning it all off
you've been through hell
what are some of your injuries involved
in this rack
uh double two types of brain bleed
double pneumocellox broken ribs
um I almost lost my left leg I had to
relearn how to walk
I have an awesome year I had to have
bladder surgery I probably will never be
able to get pregnant
pretty pretty awful
and how has the
medical system navigating that mess in
Canada been
amazing like I have
um excellent hair excuse me excellent
Healthcare and excellent support
and even though you know kovid for some
surgeries take a long time to get around
to me because I was no longer emergent
after you know you're patched up enough
to be alive
um I've gotten surgeries that have
increased my quality of life which I'm
thankful for wonderful
um what about the legal mess
oh God the legal mess is a mess up here
in Canada we have a process known as the
catastrophic process when you have
injuries as severe as mine
um and it's just long you know it's
going to take a long time to settle
because they're looking forward in my
life and the quality of my life you know
10 20 years from now and what these
injuries mean since they're so
life-altering so that's still ongoing
okay
what have you done in the last four
years to begin to
re-imagine and live your life
foreign
I've been in it like it's been four long
years of uh five or six appointments a
week legal or medical multiple surgeries
we're talking seven to eight surgeries
who's paying your bills
and what about your rent oh you're back
at work okay yeah
I went back to work yeah okay good for
you yeah
so
resilience is not something you can
think your way to
resilience is a scratching and clawing
one centimeter at a time one inch at a
time
and you look back
without thinking you turn your head and
you realize you have crawled and
scratched and clawed a mile
and you're not scrolling you're not
scratching and clawing anymore you're
suddenly you're you're crawling on all
fours
and then you look up and you've got
another mile
and you've got calluses on your hands
and on your feet and on your knees
and then you put one foot down and you
stand up
see what I'm saying resilience is formed
on one step after one step after one
step
not on this idea that I'm past all of
this
and what I promise you I promise you
you are stronger than you could possibly
imagine
Chantelle you got hit by a truck
and you and I are still talking
yeah I'm I'm lucky to be here and I I a
knowledge that and I accept it hold on
hold on hold on hold on you're lucky to
be here yes period move that over to the
side you are a gangster you're a badass
you're still here
you're not giving Chantelle the credit
Chantel deserves
I feel like
mentally accepted that though like that
was then and this is four years later
and I want more very good tell me what
do you want
I mean I used to run marathons okay and
I was an ecstatic person are you ever
gonna be able to run a marathon again
no okay
we have to grieve that that's a
significant loss
that is a heartbreaking loss that is you
sitting down and writing a letter to
Chantelle the marathon runner Remember
When
and now those days are over
this is sitting with a couple of
girlfriends that you really really trust
and having written a letter to Future
Chantelle
to let her know we may not have babies
and that was a part of our ride dude
that was going to be part of it
it's sitting in that ugly
and being I feel like I've been sitting
in the ugly for too long and I just want
to go like you can but I don't think
you're I don't I I think you sat in the
mess but there's some intentionality you
sat in it but there's there's work right
so if you if your sewer
uh here here at my house I live out in
the woods here so I've got a septic tank
it's not connected to the Sewer right I
can go sit in the septic tank if it's if
it's got a if it's broken it's
disgusting I can't think of a grosser
thing to do I'd go sit in my septic tank
I can sit there for years
but there's there's nothing productive
that I've done I've done any of the work
and if I try to go back inside my house
my wife would be like get away from my
front porch
and I'd end up just outside I'd end up
in the wilderness right
so there's something about using the
being intentional in the Darkness
instead of just sitting in it and then
wishing I wasn't in it anymore I don't
want you in it either
but I also want you to to with both
hands grab a hold of reality
and that's so hard man because this
wreck took everything from you it took
your passions it took your future to
this this picture you had of what a
family might look like you're gonna have
a family that's gonna look different but
this is what this picture was gonna look
like and here's the process and it took
that from you
that's a that's a that's a stone cold
reality that happened
and then what comes next
so you can't you can't run marathons
what's next
I don't know I'm trying to figure that
out no you got to say it you've thought
of something you've looked it up on the
internet during one of your Dark Nights
of the Soul what is it
I haven't maybe I'm just too stuck on
what was
part of the healing process part of part
of the counseling you know with
therapists and physios has been maybe we
gotta let it go maybe you got to find a
new passion but I don't know how
I haven't found something that breathes
the same light to my soul yet
there was a moment years before you ran
a mirror your first marathon
when like my seven-year-old little girl
just takes off running through the yard
and her little blonde hair is flying all
backwards and she's running so slow but
she thinks she is running a thousand
miles an hour
and she can run for about 50 yards
before she's sucking wind can't breathe
and that was the Genesis
of her wanting to run more and more and
there was a moment when that was you
it was a few steps that put wind in your
hair
and put a smile on your face and over
time that turned into marathons
what you have to be willing to do the
The Bravery you've got in your guts the
Courage the moment of Courage you've got
in front of you is this
I gotta take a few steps towards
something
with one day I might be able to run a
marathon whatever that looks like I'm
gonna pick up a guitar and I'm gonna
figure out how to play this thing
because one day I might play live
I am going to start a women's group for
people who get hit by trucks and it's
going to be awkward and weird and so
uncomfortable because one day I might
help heal families
I'm going to start the adoption process
you see what I'm saying
yep
I can't tell you how bad the world needs
you let's take another step
just in a New Direction
are you in
I'm in
here's your first two steps I want you
to write Chantelle the the athlete the
runner a letter
and tell her what an honor it was to do
life with her how much fun y'all had how
many Adventures you went on and then to
as you end that letter the last half
page the last two pages
let her know and life threw us a
curveball
actually life hit us with like a truck
and now we're gonna have to make some
changes and it's been an honor
and we're gonna do something different
now
and that's not going to be the insta
cure but what we're going to begin to do
is teach our body that that was then and
that was a part of me that will always
be a part of me and that part is that
season is over
and now what's going to come next
and I promise you if you spend some time
maybe you can't see it but sit with a
couple of girlfriends and say we gotta
come up with 10 things and I gotta try
them I gotta take 50 yard dash in 10
different directions not literally but
figuratively 50 yard dashing in either
direction remember seven-year-old
Chantel running for the first time just
sprinting her little heart out
what's that next step
resilience is not something you can just
wake up in half it's something that you
find it's a strength and strength comes
from pushing against heavy things
against resistance
that's where strength comes from
I promise you you're worth it
I promise you